the report issued today by the CDC that
looks at the prevalence of autism an
eight year old children and what they're
reporting is an overall rate of about
one in 88 children diagnosed with an
autism spectrum disorder much higher for
boys than girls one in 54 for boys and
about 1 and 250 for girls and this has
drawn attention because it's a much
higher estimate that had previously been
given by the CDC in 2009 we don't know
the exact reasons behind the increase in
prevalence there are probably many
different contributing causes we're much
better at recognizing autism now there's
much greater awareness it's picked up in
younger children in older adults and
people with milder symptoms and people
with strong our cognitive abilities
there's been a cultural change in the
past autism suggested problems with
parenting and now we know it's a
biological disorder so clinicians no
longer hesitant to give a diagnosis in
the same way so all of these kinds of
things have increased the likelihood
that a child would get an autism
diagnosis we don't know whether they
account for all of the increase we're
seeing we know that autism is a genetic
disorder but we also know there are
environmental components so we don't
know if something in the world the
children is changing that is actually
having more children develop the
disorder prevalence estimates are fairly
consistent around the globe there's been
a study in Korea that showed much higher
estimates about 26 in a thousand
children I think that people are trying
to understand there's a great deal of
research right now trying to understand
what environmental factors could
contribute I think the most important
thing to take away is that this is no
matter the reason for these change in
numbers this is an estimate of the
number of children who need help and we
need to keep understanding how to pick
these children up and how to treat them
optimally so they can live the most
fulfilling lives that they're able to do
in this study we examined a large data
set that was collected in the context of
the field trial done in the early
he's an international field trial with
over 100 clinicians and over a thousand
patients and what we did is we tried to
get a sense of among the people who
would have been clinically diagnosed
with an autism spectrum disorder in that
study how many would meet the proposed
criteria in the new edition of the DSM
which is the book that gives the classf
it that the rules for diagnosing people
with psychiatric disorders and what we
found is that there were a significant
group of people who wouldn't meet dsm-5
criteria about sixty percent did but
there was a big group of people about
forty percent that did not and this was
most pronounced among people with
stronger cognitively cognitive abilities
and it varied by diagnosis so people
with autism proper autistic disorder
tended to meet dsm-5 criteria while
people with Asperger's syndrome or
pervasive developmental disorder not
otherwise specified were less likely to
meet it's not known what will happen to
people who no longer meet criteria for
autism in terms of services and care
they would no longer qualify under an
autism spectrum diagnosis however there
are new diagnoses being added like
social communication disorder some of
them would undoubtedly fall into that
category but we don't know what that
means for services because it's a
totally new diagnosis so that it's not
written into the laws it's not built
into school education plans so it's very
unclear exactly what the impact on
access to services would be
the DSM is a diagnostic and statistical
manual of mental disorders it's in its
it's currently in its fourth edition the
fifth edition is being prepared it's
overseen by the American Psychiatric
Association and there's a task force a
neurodevelopmental disorders workgroup
that's specifically working on autism
and other disorders of childhood there
are changes expect in dsm-5 they're two
kinds of changes one is largely semantic
they're going to collapse right now
three diagnosis that are autism spectrum
disorders autism Asperger's disorder and
pervasive developmental disorder not
otherwise specified into a single
category called autism spectrum
disorders but they're also changing the
actual diagnostic criteria themselves so
you'll need to have a more consistent
profile of social communicative
difficulties and you'll need to show
more repetitive restricted behaviors
than you presently have to the change in
the diagnostic criteria could certainly
affect the prevalence rate at CDC
studies pick up it's not certain how it
will affect them our study suggested
it's a more stringent set of criteria
that less people would meet criteria
there are other studies have that have
found similar results there are other
studies that have suggested there's not
going to be that much change so far
we've seen the impact on prevalence is
very tightly related to the kind of
study that's done whether it's a current
or historical data set whether it's
using parent report or clinician
observation will have the best sense of
what the impact will be when the field
trials are published and we have a
current set of evaluations that involve
parent report and clinician evaluation
that directly contrast dsm four criteria
with dsm-5 criteria only then when we
really understand how it's going to
impact autism prevalence the main
takeaways from our paper are that that
should the plan changes could impact who
meets or doesn't meet criteria but I
think that it's premature to worry the
the criteria are not set in stone
and the people thinking about them and
finally finalizing them are listening
and paying attention to the results of
our study and other studies and the
neurodevelopmental disorders work group
has the best interests of these families
in mind it's a balance between making
sure that we are doing the best that we
can do in terms of making sure that
people who have autism get diagnosed
with autism and that people who don't
get diagnosed with the right disorder or
referred to the kinds of help that they
need if it's not something in the DSM
you